want to see uh i want to see a power
couple emerge
here in 2020. if there's any power
couple
if there's any e-celeb power couple
that could better represent the year
2020
in this country it's these two
i'm serious these two when you look at
2020
uh the riots the looting the police
brutality
uh the the terrible debates the awful
[ __ ] candidates in
all offices across america
who better to represent the [ __ ] year of
2020.
we might as well make these two our prom
king and queen i think
anyway i say baked alaska sammy
power couple prom king and queen of
2020.
nebula says they should move to florida
together you know what
part of me wants to wants to do the
whole like oh don't do that to us man
don't do that to florida man we deserve
we don't deserve it but let's be fair
they would make an amazing florida
couple
they really would they would make the
quintessential florida
couple they just picture them living out
in like
newport richie you know somewhere in
[ __ ]
nah alan they're not quite ebor city
material these two are more pasco county
material
i would put these two up near holiday
newport richie maybe spring hill area um
they would be perfect for pasco county
these would be the pasco county
prom king and queen um
somebody said what the [ __ ] is all that
[ __ ] on the sink
uh those are all her various
moisturizers and what have you you see
uh maybe you weren't here trolita for
the last episode see this young
beautiful vibrant young woman lives in
an rv that's parked in the desert in
tempe arizona
so to answer your question that is
both her kitchen and her bathroom sink
[Laughter]
so you know that might be that might be
why there's like moisturizer
uh a [ __ ] uh hot curling iron
and and and all that [ __ ] next to like
palm olive and dirty dishes
so anyway when we left off we got back
to her house she was giving him the tour
she was throwing them vibes dare i say
and uh we had to cut it off because we
were like
well these episodes have turned into
three hour
mega episodes uh so here it is guys
we're gonna pick up where we left off
we're in the uh the bedroom section of
the rv
where the magic happens and uh here we
go
and then i have a closet oh wow
master bedroom closet wow stop saying
master bedroom you live in an rv
by the way she keeps on ironically
calling it a master bedroom there's no
listen a master bedroom very
specifically
very specifically a master bedroom
is a bedroom within the home that's
generally the largest bedroom
and has its own separate bathroom that
is what a master bed master bedroom is
basically other than the kitchen i got
everything i need in one room you know
what i mean the master bedrooms
the best bedroom to be to get sick in
if you're sick having a master bedroom
rules
you know what i mean because you can
just quarantine a sick person in there
and go like just go there your bathroom
in there
i'll slide soup under the door um
but this is not a master bedroom this is
a bed in an rv
i don't know if you can see that but she
apparently started eating mac and cheese
and gave up
eating the mac and cheese
and then just left a bowl of mac and
cheese
with mac and cheese in it now look if
you're gonna a little tip in life there
folks
um because i eat a lot of garbage food
i'm not a healthy guy
mac and cheese is something i've very
frequently consumed
um when you make things that have cheese
sauce or any kind of cheese
by-product the greatest thing to do is
to clean it immediately
um if you're done with what's in the
bowl scrape it out of the bowl rinse the
bowl out
the sooner you soak and rinse the bowl
the easier it will be to get that cheese
off when you're ready to clean the bowl
when i make mac and cheese and i admit i
make like
shitty out of the box mac and cheese but
when i make mac and cheese i usually
make the [ __ ] that has the cheese sauce
like the velveeta um
if it's if you make your mac and cheese
you know you boil you strain it
throw the macaroni back in the pot throw
the cheese in the pot and you mix it in
very simple
i won't even sit down to eat my mac and
cheese unless i've taken i dump it all
in a bowl
and i immediately take the pot and i
immediately rinse it out
i immediately rinse it out and sew and
put a little bit of dish soap in it
and then fill it up all the way so that
it
you know what i mean so that next time
when you're ready to wash the pot
literally one wipe around with a [ __ ]
sponge it's done
it's you don't leave cheesy things to
just sit
they will [ __ ] be as hard as the bowl
itself
and like i literally when i was in my
20s
like i would and i [ __ ] you not i've
done this in multiple apartments
um i've thrown dishes out you know what
i mean like in my 20s
i would do [ __ ] like this girls doing
like i'd make mac and cheese
and then i would just like you know the
next day you'd see a bowl with like
hardened mac and cheese i just [ __ ]
throw the bowl out
and just go to walmart bowls
[ __ ] kid like there have been dishes
in the past that i was like
yeah i'm not washing that you just
[ __ ] you just throw it out i'll go
get some new dishes
it's really not a big deal you know what
i mean like i've had pans that were like
that too he just ruined the pan
and it's like oh man how do i get this
pan clean it's like oh let's just go to
target
i'll buy another pan it's not
just throw it out it's what's the point
because it's like either throw it out
and spend like 10 bucks on a new dish or
a new bowl
or spend like 40 minutes trying to scrub
that bowl
[ __ ] you dude i just buy a new bowl
please don't eat that ever don't eat
that okay
oh you got a fridge nice oh i have a
bottle of applesauce that my boyfriend
opened that i don't
trust okay you know what i haven't said
this yet since we've been watching sammy
but i think it's about time
somebody says it and i hate to speak in
memes
but it has to be done damn do you really
live like this
by the way i've never
when i was like when i was a bachelor
when i was like a 20-something year old
bachelor and i was out doing
every night like when i was living
in a shitty house that had
three strippers two bouncers
and a biker from a local biker gang all
living in the same house
my fridge didn't look like that you know
what i mean like i've lived alone in
shitty apartments
my fridge never was this barren i mean
i've had some pretty barren fridges but
you know it's it's usually something in
there usually a couple of gatorades a
beer
at least a couple beers that i could
offer a guest
yeah and then i opened a bottle of mac
and broccoli cheese soup and i think it
smelled funny so i don't i don't eat
that either
sonic i thought the other day i have
some water
um like i just i just buy food as i go
because
what about what's in the freezer you got
some ice cream somebody bought for me a
long time ago
it's got little bugs and like this thing
that goes through your intestines
yeah what's in the freezer you got some
ice cream
oh
do you have any hand sanitizer by chance
[Laughter]
okay sorry you know what i you know i
very rarely he says something that makes
me laugh
and i hate when i always say it's very
rare that i have to begrudgingly admit
that faith alaska
can be funny and that's actually i don't
even know if he was intentionally funny
but that was funny like that the timing
of that
i don't know if he really meant it on
ironically enough but just the way he
just
yeah yeah yeah that's great you got a
hand sanitizer
bleach [ __ ] ammonia i can spray all
over this way
i gotta hear that again i'm sorry it's
just the way he the way he just
kind of segwayed yeah yeah yeah that's
word word
so you gotta yeah it's sanitizer uh
broccoli cheese soup
and i think it smells funny so i don't i
don't eat that either
yeah it was a little [ __ ] welter i'm
sure it wasn't intentional but it was
funny
i just i just buy food as i go cause
what about what's in the freezer you got
some ice cream
somebody bought for me a long time ago
it's got little
bugs and like this thing that goes
through your
intestines yeah what's in the freezer
you got some ice cream
tropical immunity okay i'm sorry but
that's a very good line
j forever king in the chat says even
rigs from lethal weapon had
beers in the fridge this is i made for
my oh yeah you should
you should i made that out of a bread
thing because you should apply some ice
on that
do you have any hand sanitizer by chance
oh and then i have that hand sanitizer
by chance
she doesn't by the way
she she isn't baked
we started watching this a week ago
and we got to part two what was that
tuesday
tuesday night we did part two
and in the time baked made it back to
this rv
i've watched baked alaska
try to interject and have a conversation
at least at least a dozen times
since he's been in the start he's been
in this rv realistically
about 10 minutes now
he has tried every angle even acid do
you have any handset
hey excuse me real quick do you have any
oh nice freeze do you have any
nothing she just babbles and babbles and
babbles and babbles and it's like
oh boy i have seen girls like this
before i don't know what she's on she's
definitely on something
um
they they when a girl does something
like this
and she just isn't listening and she's
showing you things nervously and talking
that there is something going on i don't
know if she's on antipsychotics
i don't know if she's on dru she's on
something
she's on something because she's a
[ __ ] [ __ ] show
can you hear me can you hear me
do you have a hand sanitizer thing
wait what is zest hand sanitizer okay
could you
spray a little on my hand please
thank you i appreciate that
um other than that i'm just a normal
girl i have like
you know normal girl stuff
like an rv ah it's nice
i have normal girl stuff you know like
an rv full of rotten food and pink eye
normal where is it where's
here we go i'm just thinking of uh i'm
trying to find um
all right there we go can somebody do me
a favor
i know every time i say that it creates
work for people so i'm sorry
can we get some of our photoshop people
she's like oh and then i got just a
bunch of girly things can we flee thank
you
see eric fernandez knew eric knew
exactly where i was going with this
could someone please make memes like
this
but it's like you know uh uh
contracting pinkeye and your filthy rv
in the desert
just girly things you know what i mean
or or uh
leaving rotten balls of macaroni and
cheese in your shitty rv
just girly things
making making a [ __ ] making a uh
making a homemade ice pack and keeping
in your freezer because your pimp
boyfriend knocked your lights out
just girly things
by the way eric was on top that he knew
exactly where i was going with it
it's not bad in here you got a little
apartment can you play us a song on the
guitar
just whatever okay you wanna hear the
first song i ever learn
yeah okay ready
d-a-g d-a-g-a
d-a-g she just starts playing smoke on
the water
[Music]
larry marilyn says marsh have you ever
walked out on some because the house was
so gross um
yes but
i wasn't there to get so it wasn't like
i went back with this chick
um there was a girl who
lived with or was related to
this guy uh rj that i used to get weed
from
in north carolina um
trailer park called holiday city i
wonder if it's still there
i wonder if holiday city is still there
what a [ __ ] [ __ ] hole that was
um but holiday city was this trailer
park it was
real bad it was the worst trailer park
in the area and i would go there to get
weed sometimes and they these people
lived in
like deplorable subhuman conditions
um but i would i would go get weed there
and i think
there was one of the girls there that
wanted to [ __ ] me
and i was like and she was she was cute
but you know i was like this isn't
these aren't great conditions you know
what i mean like she was alright looking
but i'm like if you live like this i
can't imagine
what's going on you know under your
clothes
do you sing too i used to
but then people made fun of me so much
that i gave up
but oh no you're funny
[Music]
this is oh i'm cringing
[Music]
yeah keep going that's amazing you're
good
you're really good
[Music]
song [ __ ] stop
[Music]
don't mind me
[Music]
[Music]
by the way that thing is so badly tuned
i don't know when the last time
she tuned that guitar is but
that is not a well-tuned guitar and if
she lives out in the desert like
it um
i can't remember is it is it the dry
weather that [ __ ] up guitars or is it
or is it humid weather i don't know i
think both are kind of bad for guitars
but she's in an rv in the desert there's
no way that thing
is tuned well
people are calling her trailer swift
ha ha people are oh sorry i clicked on
the people are calling her
trailer swift hill chill chill
you're good you're actually good i'm
surprised trailer swift
that's not really good
no you're good you're i ever good
it goes like this
[Music]
stop your piece of [ __ ]
stop you piece of [ __ ]
i love the internet
stop you piece of [ __ ]
so simple stop you fake catholic piece
of [ __ ]
chill chill chill they're yelling at
[Music]
baked
[Music]
[Music]
i'm
you're good oh man this girl's
nuts the [ __ ] mood changes and stuff
she's
and don't get me wrong like i you know
look
i find this girl kind of hateable just
because she's another
spoiled babbling in another
symptom of western culture's decline
but i don't hate her as much as i would
normally hate
a crazy one um
you know i kind of feel bad for this one
because this one
you almost feel like with this one maybe
with a little bit of medication
and the right people in her life
she could maybe get out of
whatever situation she's in um
it's it's not like some of the other
like some of these other sushi and
streams that you just
like you know corrine and some of these
girls that you're like god damn it
um but there's something about this one
that i feel kind of
feel kind of bad about you know what i
mean